you've been in jail a lot no since 2018
i've been going back to back to back to
back [ __ ] bad luck
you know for sure that i didn't even do
it
i just get going the wrong place at the
wrong time
drugs
all right arnie yes ernie uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
oh i grew up in mexico city guadalajara
and uh i came to the states when i was
young like you know 13.
and now i've been here since since 13.
uh i went to high school here
and uh i went to the navy right after
high school and um
i had a lot of experiences in the navy
you know like a lot of crazy [ __ ] i've
seen
i've seen people coming suicide again i
i basically went to war
my ship i was an um aircraft carrier
of cvn 68 uss nimitz
aircraft carrier um i used to work on
the flight deck
you know and my ship was the first one
to respond to the iraqi freedom campaign
you know fresh out of [ __ ] you know
a school from pensacola i got to the
boat
and two days later i'm gonna like going
there's a persian gulf
on the boat and the boat is hauling ass
on the water
like it's amazing those boats are like
humongous and they [ __ ] go through
the water like
like if they're [ __ ] like mini boats
speed balls
don't stop don't stop and and like i
said i've seen people commit suicide
i see people die for for you know
accidents
you know and i've seen a lot of
discrimination
racism you know blacks with the blacks
mexicans like
like you kind of gel thing you know i
mean the mexicans held mexicans
the the whites help you know the whites
and [ __ ] like that you know
like dumb [ __ ] even though you're your
brothers
you know but like that's how
i have my experience in name you know
and um
i got out in 2005 may 2005
from the navy and um
how long they took me i think it took me
like
um maybe like two months
i think and then um i started using
drugs and i
was drinking i started drinking heavily
on the boat
every chance i had i gave myself a
bottle
and my friends you know like my friends
they used to work as amazed military
police right
i mean mps excuse me
you know so this allowed me to bring
bottles of liquor
on the boat it was illegal but i used to
bring him
you know i was an alcoholic hardcore
alcoholic at the moment
you know i was going through ptsd
but i didn't know what was ptsd from
what
the things you saw from things i had i
had
seen experience and
things that i live you know i mean i
should be afraid to work on the fly deck
i used to be [ __ ] scared like a
little sisi
it's the [ __ ] movement there
it's amazing planes landing
taking off bombs here bombs there
missiles like [ __ ] pilots getting off
going on taking off all that crisp
planes landing it's like it's madness
it's madness i think i forgot the exact
number i think it was
we carry 72 planes jets you know fight
bombers and fighters and six helicopters
on the fly deck
when everything was parked you know
and um that's a lot of [ __ ]
movement you know that's a lot of
[ __ ] movement you know
and and we should work sometimes like 12
hours
straight 14 hours straight you know
and we're like we're in a person golf
right and
and the weather on the persian gulf
we're on the ocean
right on the open ocean and um the ship
gotta be doing
all circle eight figures so with the
the way the the planes can land on the
on the boat
the ball gotta be on a certain speed so
that the plane can come
and catch the wires and stop you know
well um
that [ __ ] [ __ ] gets me
it's [ __ ] bad [ __ ] man i hate that
[ __ ]
i don't talk about this [ __ ] with no
audience like i hate that [ __ ]
you know what was the worst worst part
of what you went through
[ __ ] i can say working on the flight
deck like i said
like my my
my job that i had assigned
when i signed in on maps
oh i took the the test to see what kind
of job you qualify for
and they say oh we need oh we need um
air crew man yeah air crew
air crew um
what was the name [ __ ]
air crew non-swimmer search and rescue
teams
people right so i thought it was cool
you know
because of the on the thing said
non-swimmer
right meaning that i had to be in the
helicopter helping
do whatever holding the gun or doing
whatever right on the helicopter
that's what i thought right
so i go to boot camp and then i get to a
school
and i get to a school and there's
[ __ ] big ass [ __ ] pools
100 feet by 100 feet by 100 feet 20 feet
deep
i've been i've been on the water before
i've been in the water before
but like i'm not a [ __ ] professional
swimmer
and and they have us [ __ ] jump from
like 25 feet
[ __ ] platforms to the water first is
normal
like it's like whatever's on shorts you
know and a t-shirt or
you know you jump and you swim
underwater on top of the water whatever
it's like nothing you know but they're
just like kinda
like trying to induce you not to be
scared
right and then and then and then it
starts getting
like more intense then then they say oh
you guys are ready you know after like a
week or two you guys are ready
now you guys gotta wear comeback boots
and jump and then you gotta you gotta
either swim on the water on top of the
water
and you got boots and the boots get
heavy
super heavy in the water you can't even
[ __ ] move you know
especially if you're not on how to swim
and then and then
and then you wear coveralls and comeback
boots
and help me you know and goggles
like full gear like if you're in a
helicopter and you jump in the water
and then you swim out and then and then
they start like giving you different
tests you know
like they put you on a on a helicopter
cabin
it's a simulator you know it's like 25
25 feet high
and then and then you get a seat belt
right here
and then boom the the
the the the test is that they gotta drop
you
and then and then it's simulated right
so it's a crash
the helicopter comes crashed into the
water
and it [ __ ] like like the water goes
in in in the
in the simulator real fast you catch
water so
on your mind you you're thinking like
i'm studying [ __ ] like i can do it real
quick and get out you know i mean
but like it's [ __ ] hard you panic
you [ __ ] panic i don't give a [ __ ]
who the person is
every single person that took that test
the first thing they fail
you like like you hit the water
and it like just just the noise of the
impact it's like oh [ __ ]
and then the water comes in and you're
trying to find the buckle
like to get her off and you can get her
off
and you're drowning but like there's
divers
watching you right and and
the only the only way they can help you
that's when you let go
when you let go that's when they they
like they help you they get the shield
off and they get you off and they make
you like you know i mean
throw water out but it's scary that's a
[ __ ] scary ass feeling
drowning it's a nastiest feeling it's
not a [ __ ]
nasty as that for somebody you know very
stressful
[ __ ] yeah it's it's traumatic yeah so
that that
led you to drinking yeah yeah
and and it was it just it's just madness
you know
and then you have to jump on our pool
with like full gear
and you have to do 10 laps without
touching the the edge of the pool
10 laps any any any kind of different
stroke that you you practice or you was
good at or you could switch different
strokes it was 10 laps
that's a lot of swimming bro that's a
lot of swimming
a lot like i i forgot exactly the number
but like i can see like out of five five
people
one succeed and that was like
because he was like already like a
swimmer at high school
or he was like into swimming on the
street you know
like his people had a pool whatever you
know it was just crazy it was crazy
yeah it was just [ __ ] madness you
know
and you know like on the flight like
when i used to work
it was like i should work at nighttime
and at night time
i know you've ever seen it on discovery
channel they got like
the ship got like um lights
on the flight deck right and they go
they go by colors
it's nighttime bro you're tired after
like 10 hours of work and
and um the room
you step on the wrong line at the wrong
moment
like even though if you just like cross
the line just like
a feet like one foot inside of the line
your wrist anything can happen to you
the the the turbine can suck you in
the the excess of the the jet can burn
you and throw you off the fly deck
you know and then um it was a hundred
from the flight deck
to the water level it was 104 feet high
it was a drop of 104 feet so
imagine you you you get throughout the
flight deck
and um you go in the ocean
the ship is moving bro the ship is
moving
you got you got like uh like a live vest
and everything you know in case you
you hurt yourself whatever you go
unconscious
like but like like [ __ ] like
it it's it's a secure day it's for sure
then
you're in the ocean and it's 104 feet
drop
if you fall anyway any any any
any way wrong you're gonna you're gonna
break something
you're gonna break your back or or
you're gonna get hurt
how the [ __ ] you're gonna ask like put a
light on your helmet so they can see you
you know how are you gonna put uh like
like like those those so honeycomb
those candles that that you break in the
first person
the flare you know how you can do that
when you're like
like hurt you know like like the guy
that's incumbent suicide
the ship was moving and the dude
when you work on them on inside ship you
can wear covers and boots and a hat
right but the dude had copper also he
didn't he didn't have anything
in the in the inside he was naked so he
just got to the to the
to the um elevator that ever was down
and now [ __ ] dude you stick the
cobras real fast and the boots and he
jump on the water he took
he took everybody by surprise
everybody's like what the [ __ ]
like that do you just jump in the water
that like the helicopters come
come out whatever for for rescue
wore the body at the ship is moving like
i said
you know where the body at the body was
never found
anybody any anybody could do that
[ __ ] what do you think drove him to that
huh what do you think drove him to do
that
strategy the stress it's the strange bro
it's it's it's crazy
you know i got a lot of respect for my
other um
mother veterans you know that that like
get through whatever training and they
don't have no bad experiences
and i give them a lot of a lot of like
um props you know
this is stuff it's real tough like
like i just recently just recently got
got released from um county jail and i
went to a program to get my life better
right
try to [ __ ]
i had a i had a it was just me and
another veteran right
but he was a marine and it was [ __ ]
crazy
he's [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ] crazy
he he he's the reason why i left the
program pretty much i can say that
he made me have [ __ ] like flashbacks
like crazy
he's talking about she's like oh yeah i
got blown out of my [ __ ] jeep and
like my home being [ __ ] like you know
what i mean i got i got i got brain
surgery and blah blah blah like talking
about like like it's nothing you know
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] like what the
[ __ ]
if if i cut myself on the finger i'll be
like oh you know
imagine give it like brain surgery like
what the [ __ ]
and you're like he's he's acting like
he's a gang banger
you're looking like you said gangbanger
and [ __ ] like talking about like drugs
and this and that
i'm like bro you know nothing about
drugs you know what i mean i've been
homeless for [ __ ] like
nine years you know what i mean in
downtown skid row
when i got here to skip bro oh my god
i'm mexican i'm light skinned
like i'm talking discriminatory or
nothing but you see the community
you know what it is 90 plan exactly
so at the beginning who's that
who's that he got money they used to
give me at the beginning
some people used to serve me dope right
and it was good
it was [ __ ] hella good you know
and then and then i come back
with like more money right and uh
they give me bunk they give me pieces of
you know
to see if i come back to see who i am
you know if i'm i'm a real drug addict
because i
like i hardly let myself go look i don't
think i look too dirty
you know i like i like taking care of
myself
to the best ability if i can even though
i'm on the streets
you know what can i tell you like
like you know i have i have i have been
around like for too long now
that like you know a lot of people know
me you know
and they know you know like
i like networking with people like being
friendly you know
if they need to fix a bike or whatever
if if i can do it i'll do it
or they need something i'll do it you
know
and that's how sometimes i you know they
bless me with money
you know they like that's how you
support yourself
well if you get to support myself
sometimes some days i don't even make
not even one dollar
because i like begging people for money
that's not my get down
you know but like i can tell you
that uh there's some people that know me
right that they know like i
i like walking a lot right i like to
move around
because you never know what you're going
to find you know
you never know what's yours is yours you
know like that's my mentality
you know like like there's this creator
and even though i do drugs that's wrong
he's the one that takes care of me you
know on my craziness
when i get crazy like on drugs and [ __ ]
and um he's the one takes care of me
that nothing happens to me
you know what what drugs are you using
today today i asked use christmas
you know i haven't used no heroin today
because i got no money
but normally you're using meth heroin uh
well when i get it i like heroin too
and drinking and yeah if if i got money
or somebody buys for me you know like i
was going up the street
and one guy that i know from like you
know from time
he's like hey what's up barney you know
and i don't know
i don't i don't know what he gave me he
just give me bill
i i just put in my pocket you know i'm
gonna be like
you know i just put my pocket i said
thank you for
i love you you know like i don't mean
like like gaily or nothing like that you
know
like me love thank you you know
yeah and and i can go ask people
maybe for for like you know for drugs
sometimes
and they say oh yeah fool sit down
what are you doing she's down so talk to
your family
yeah i do talk to my my family
you know my i can see my my
my people some of them they're like
like middle class rich people
and some other like the other half is
like middle class whatever you know
like they they have helped me before
but they have pushed me
away from the family because they have
kids i got nephews and nieces and some
of them they're
they're little you know and and like
like the older ones i have they're all
the ones i have
the other one is 18. um
[ __ ] like it was tough because i i like
i still like going to their house and
biking you know
taking my bike and go biking with them
just have fun you know
but like my my brother-in-law used to
say hey bro
you know we love you and everything but
like [ __ ]
you can hide it it looks like you're
[ __ ] high you're [ __ ]
doing your [ __ ] and i got my i got my i
got my kids
your nephews your knees right and i
don't want them
to have your examples
in the house if i don't do drugs if i
don't drink
i don't even drink coffee why am i
having my house
you know risking my kids to see you
coming down from drugs or having drugs
you know i mean that's a bad
example you know and um
mothers have family too they do the same
thing you know
say say you know what we love you we can
help you whenever we're like you know
whatever shoes or some clothes
if you need them you know but we really
we got kids
you know we need the money for a rent
for food for whatever you know
and i respect that i don't ask him for
nothing
i don't ask him for nothing i call my
mom once in a while you know
especially when i'm in the county like i
call once a week because it's a free
call
so i make sure you know i call my mind
my mom and i chitchat
you know i mean hey what's up what are
you doing you know i call her
i call her singing little hour and used
to you know mess around
oh [ __ ] so you stink you stay where in
the tent
no i can be in a tent i get paranoid as
[ __ ]
so you just you if you're doing crystal
meth you're probably not sleeping a lot
anyway
um you know like i know a bunch of
people around bro
you know you you hear me saying saying
somebody's name
you know hey you know because they know
me i'm from
i'm part of the area you know it's like
right now right now i'm still fresh out
of county so it's just a lot of people
that still
can't recognize me still you know but
like
after a week or so there's gonna be a
bunch of people that know me
and there's a bunch of people in the
area that see me walking around yeah and
you have no kids
yeah i got a daughter you do yeah i got
a daughter she's 12 years old
where is she oh [ __ ] good question
that's a good question
i wish i could answer that question
yeah where do you see your life going
now how old are you excuse me how
how old are you i'm 39 right now you're
not where do you see your
life going now [ __ ]
honestly honestly i see
like my life if if if
if i keep on doing what i'm doing right
now like hitting the brakes you know
on drugs and like [ __ ] you know
i see myself um maybe in a job
you know on a good job because i know
how to do
different [ __ ] you know i'm really good
at construction
demolition you know i know how to work
different things you know
so i know i can give a good job you know
i just gotta go
gotta have the right help
you know to to like
obtain sobriety
and i see myself i don't know i don't
know the period of time
but i see myself with a girl kids
like new kids i and and
i really wanted like from from the
bottom of my heart like dipping me
i i want my car
i want my apartment and i don't want no
sro
you know there's nothing wrong with it
but i don't know what's
wrong i think i think i think if i put
myself to it
i can i can i can support myself you
know i can go back to normal society
you know maybe i can do my drugs as um
how do you call that um
[ __ ] um
oh [ __ ] i can think of the warrior
[ __ ] whenever you do drugs like for
recreation you know on the weekends
you know maybe if i can be able to do
that that'd be cool
but if i can stop it at all i will i
will
shin there's a lot of girls that [ __ ]
walk around i'll be like
well you know they're like they're like
man i got a job
and i got what you got
what's your childhood like excuse me
close your childhood like
ah it was tough
my dad i don't talk bad about him you
know
but my dad comes from a really like
tough family you know my
my grandfather he was really really real
strict
you know oh he was a butcher
in mexico you know and um
i think my dad was 14 or 15 years old
when he started like slaughtering
animals killing animals
for selling meat and stuff you know
and he was real tough you know
if i'll do something wrong he will get
like anything
a piece of wood or cables and he will
hit me with the cables and no one time
he'll hit me like i told you not to do
it
you know what i mean and i like
everything my dad is strong
he's kind of short but he's stucky you
know he's strong
and he he used to hit me hard i was a
little kid you know
and every every single time he hit me
with a wire or with the belt
he marked me you know it was a mark
you know [ __ ] that [ __ ] hurts that [ __ ]
hurts you know
and that's how you learn how how to
[ __ ] listen i guess
you know that's the way of him teaching
us
to listen to pay attention to whatever
he was saying you know
by i guess putting fear on us that's
what he tried to do you know
that's why like like he's cool
i think it's cool but like if i have
if i have the chance not to be around
him
i can do that you know because i got it
of a lot of like
like how can i say it like i got a lot
of
resentment on him you know
like i i would like to i would like to
ask him one day like hey
remember the day that you [ __ ] me up
why you [ __ ] me up like that
you know there was no need to [ __ ] me
over like that you know remember the day
you kicked me you you kicked him in the
ass real hard
they threw me like [ __ ] like feet
away like damn what do you do that for
you know i was a little uh i was a
little kid you know
you want to try and doing it do it right
now you know like we like to try it
right now
i'm a grown person now i can defend
myself you know
it's like [ __ ] i just i just
don't know how to do it you know he's
tough i know if i say anything about
anything like that
it's gonna be a fight you know maybe not
fist fight
but it's gonna be a real fight like
maybe we're gonna stop talking it's
gonna be for a long time
you know he thinks he right now he's
all you know he's on his 50s and
he changed his life now he thinks about
god
talks about god you know god is coming
god's gonna forgive you
i pray for you but i think that's too
late already
you know i needed that [ __ ] when i was a
kid you know
but i've seen him [ __ ] wrong with
hookers
you know when i was a kid you know
when i was a kid i seen i seen a guy
[ __ ] a prostitute
you know because my dad was somewhere
else
he left me in the truck waiting for him
and my dad is somewhere else
dancing with some [ __ ]
i told my mom that [ __ ] but
i came back you know and [ __ ] i know
i told him i told my mom
my mom is number one for me my mom
[ __ ] i killed for my mom
you know if anybody if i can just do
anything to my mom
i'll [ __ ] kill somebody from my mom
if i have to
you know but like [ __ ]
i told my mom you know what [ __ ] you
know the place my dad goes a lot
you know the whatever [ __ ] bar water
[ __ ] to talk to his friends about
business whatever
guess what i see my dad dancing with
some [ __ ] he wasn't slaying
like funny you know and um my mom got
off on him you know
so he got really mad at me he [ __ ]
grabbed me by the hand
kicked him in the ass [ __ ]
he said this is for [ __ ] being um a
[ __ ] um
she's muscle you know for telling on me
and then and then from the day on oh
my daddy to take me with him everywhere
everywhere you know that's how they do
in mexico you go with your dad
the girls stay with the mom you know and
i used to be with my dad everywhere
you know i should see how he used to
interact with people whatever like
transactions
whatever you know she used to do and
he stopped he stopped
you know he said oh i can trust this guy
you know he's my son but i can trust him
and he stopped taking me with him
you stop taking me over here ernie what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
[ __ ]
man that's a tough one
the most important lesson
not to steal from people
i think you know that's bad
that's really bad you know you get
like bad karma on that [ __ ] bad
real bad like i you know mentality my
mentality
like i think you know if somebody goes
to a business
like like a warehouse or something like
that right
uh i know from experience they they are
insured you know and and they got
they got like um
oh itinerary or whatever they have right
so if there's at the end of the year
when they do taxes
they claim so much stuff missing or
damaged
and that's how they get paid right so if
somebody breaks into a warehouse
and takes one person what can take from
a warehouse bro
two bags or whatever you know what i
mean
as long as you like break anything and
do something stupid right
the vandalism that take something right
they're sure it's a business i know it's
wrong too
but whenever you need money you need
money bro especially if you sprung out
on drugs
you know like it's bad
but like it's more i think it's more
like
more like open to do
you know more like like they can forgive
you for the enemy
like i don't think god can judge you for
that you know
but if you steal from somebody like like
if i steal from you
like especially if i know if i know you
like you're my friend
and if i go to your house your tent or
your place
and i steal something from you that's
bad
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] straight
up
you know if i see somebody walking with
a [ __ ] nice bag
or whatever if i steal it from the
person or or
or rob the person that's bad that's bad
karma
because the person work for those items
you know you don't know what they what
they did
to obtain those items you know or the
money they have
you know i know that is to get money so
i don't like nobody [ __ ] jacking me
that's bad
[ __ ] all right arnie thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out here all
right thank you
you